To make our Algebra a little bit easier, I'm going to call the length of the
hypotenuse l for just a moment. We're just going to use this other variable to
describe it. We know from the Pythagorean Theorem, that if I square each of
these sides and add them together, I'll get l squared. Then, we just need to
simplify this left side of the equation. I could distribute the exponent of 2 to
all of the factors and then add like terms. Since we want to get l by itself, we
need to take the square root of both sides. Or in other words, I need to take
both sides to the 1 half power. On the right side I just get l and on the left
side, I get 2x. So, our final answer is, that the length of the hypotenuse
equals 2x.